hallo mein name ist luca und ich kaufe
mir heute einen hund die tür öffnet sich
und wie sie 3
ich hatte einfach ich nicht wo kommt
diese schicht ist glaube ich mir gedacht
ja hier warten stets viele hündchen mit
ganz eigener persönlichkeit oft ich
versuche den hund zu finden der am
besten zu dem passt viel glück okay wir
schauen uns erst mal im zwinger einfach
nur pixel eigentlich diese hunde stehen
nicht zum verkauf aber du kannst
jederzeit mit ihnen spielen
ich hätte so gern
er hat eine nase ich hab dann schnuppern
männerhand baby mach dich das geil
einen spaghetti dann kaufen wir uns aber
jetzt mal und zwar gibt es den labrador
retriever den zwergpinscher den
zwergpudel den zwergschnauzer old course
shiba inu
audi sind süß kleiner kräftiger körper
und gedrehter schwanz erinnert mich an
mich ins märkische noch ganz witzig
eigentlich ursprünglich aus deutschland
würde volles auftreten bad und
augenbrauen definieren die rasse ich
weiß nicht alter welchen unternehmen
alter sind hier herzlich um ein gott
komplett die besonderen diesem team wie
die den aus wir hatten einfach
zwergpudel zwergschnauzer oder schieber
ihn nun wir können eine münze fragen
zehn cent gefunden mit denen machen wir
das jetzt uns wir haben drei rassen
wieder zur auswahl
ich glaube ich dass den zwergschnauzer
einfach raus auf den heimischen boxer
entweder einen zwergpudel oder einen
shiba inu wir können uns ja später noch
mehrere hunde kaufen also wenn ihr er
der pudel fanseiten der über ihnen
kommen raus dann sagt nicht herr konrad
buck quartal ist pudel und kopf ist
shiba inu und ich mache wieder die
kämpfe des inders lädt und ich lasse es
fallen
oh mein gott wir haben kamera wir haben
gerade kopf bekommen aber damit niemand
meckern kann und sagen kann dass das
ganze gepflegtes lass dir irgendwie noch
mal einfach mal eben neu wäre
tatsächlich wieder kommt hier schaut wie
sie aufheben da kopf das heißt wir
entscheiden uns für den shiba inu glaube
ich in diesen männlichen schwarzen
einfach hier so bestätigen jetzt möchten
wir diese hund ja du hast dein münchen
gewesen
jetzt richtig süßes wünsche ist nur bei
dir zu hause erscheint mir böse sein
weil die umgebung fremd ist da bringe
etwas zeit mit einem hund damit er sich
etwas behaglicher führt büro das beim
fuße des bildschirms und zu rufen
okay ist das ganze ein ernster ist so
ein visionär scheint sich etwas beruhigt
zu haben sicher ist wie schon der name
für den hütchen eingefallen oder gut
denn nun soll dein hund euren namen
erhalten in dem ruin laut ausspricht
view ballo ballo ballo ballo ballo ballo
ballo ja er hat dich gehört balla balla
balla balla balla balla balla balla
balla balla
ballo ballo ballo ballo ballo endlich
endlich hat er den scheiß namen gemerkt
bardot soll heißen ja das ist in ordnung
und zwar habe ich irgendwann ja schon
mal videos gesagt möchte ich wieder wenn
ich noch etwas unbedingt blumen
das ist sondern das ist dieser name von
dem von der serie mit dem werden und dem
balu scheint sich über den namen zu
freuen
ja das sieht man ihm der wir testen
jetzt mal ob er den namen hören kann und
zwar balu ballo ballo ballo klo
dies ist ein guter zeitpunkt ein hund
das kommando sitz beizubringen streiche
den kopf am ball oder für den touch
panel schnell nach unten
sitzt sitzt merkt ihr den cheat doch
einfach ist es nicht auch mal möglich
gewesen dass man irgendwie mit dieser
glühbirne den typen noch füttern kann
was ich zeige euch mal was ich meine da
macht jetzt sitze ich sage sitz
natürlich kommt jetzt ein fragezeichen
brockmann freundin das klappt nicht
richtig mit dem ding mit dem mikrofon
ich spiele das mit dem dsd simulator
wenn ihr ideen habt wie ich da irgendwie
mein mikrofon einstellen kann dass der
das qualitativ hochwertiger machen kann
und wir diese serie eventuell fortsetzen
können dann schreib mir das bitte mal
die kommentare in welche videos oder
suizid und sonst würde ich sagen euch
das video gefallen ob ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen bei 40.000 likes da
esse ich mache ich nichts weil ich nicht
will dass ihr gezwungen werden um zu
liken ich glaube ich wäre das eine serie
machen wenn das spiel spaß macht ich
muss nur schauen mich das machen mit dem
mikrofon bis dahin sage ich erst mal
schauen und blume hatte hat die letzten
worte hier